porsha and i are sitting at home
watching as we do every saturday night
suddenly we're watching a sketch that
comes up with jason sudeikis dressed
like the male version of me and uh it
was a parody on my show what does ellen
degeneres think of jason sedakis
spoofing her daytime talk show on
saturday night live it was hilarious she
loved it you know it's the greatest
thing just in case you missed it jason
hosted snl last weekend and during the
episode he channeled his inner ellen for
a sketch titled melon where he portrayed
a male version of the 63 year old
comedian
postcoded men are staying home more than
ever before and they need a daytime talk
show that speaks to them abc thought
about it for 10 seconds and came up with
melon the male ellen i'm melon
melon all the fun daytime energy of
ellen with a hard masculine edge
melon is no holds barred in your face
entertainment
pretty funny right i think we did a
humdinger of a job melon's a man's man
and you never know what melon might do
next
[Applause]
so on thursday's episode of the real
ellen degeneres show the emmy winner
weighed in and revealed how she felt
about the whole thing i'm ellen i'm the
female ellen uh i don't know if you
watched uh snl this past weekend anybody
see sarah live
so my friend jason sedakis was hosting
and he was amazing i love jason porsche
and i are sitting at home watching as we
do every saturday night suddenly we're
watching a sketch that comes up with
jason sudeikis dressed like the male
version of me
and it was this parody on my show and
they called it melon it was hilarious
ellen shared a clip of the sketch with
the audience before wrapping up her
review
i
would actually watch that show that's a
show i would you know we should do that
after we finish this season um
we should do a show like that i loved it
i'm flattered by that and the daytime tv
host even has a proposal for jason who
is gearing up for season three of his
hit apple tv plus series ted lasso
i want to share with you all the truth
about my recent struggles with anxiety
and
well my overall concern about the way we
discuss and deal with mental health in
athletics
jason when you're done with ted lasso we
should do this show um and if you're a
studio executive you know what they say
when you have an ellen make melon of
course ellen is currently filming the
final season of her talk show today i am
announcing that next season season 19 is
going to be my last season
she announced her decision to call it
quits with season 19 back in may
after a series of allegations about the
show being a toxic workplace hit the
internet i mean it was devastating it
was it because it started with me it
started with attacks on me and attacking
everything that i
stand for and believe in and built my
career around i am
a kind person i am a
person who likes to make people happy
back in 2019 ellen told et that she
would know when it was time to move on
how are you going to know when it's the
right time to walk away from daytime i
hope i know when when people kind of are
tired of me i think i'll sense that i'll
walk away really when i when i stop
having fun
[Music]
you